Modu a 28 ans et n'a pas eu le choix.
Depuis l'âge de 8 ans, elle est femme girafe.
Lorsqu'elle a accouché de son 2e enfant,
il y a 6 mois,
on lui a permis d'enlever son collier,
mais pas pour longtemps.
Le moment est venu pour elle de le remettre.
C'est la mission de cette femme.
Certains disent que ces étranges colliers
doivent protéger les femmes des attaques de tigres,
D'autres affirment que c'est pour les embellir.
En fait, personne ne connaît la vérité,
mais dans tous les cas, Modu doit se soumettre.
- Ne serre pas trop.
- C'est dur de tordre le métal à la main.
Et puis il faut faire
de beaux cercles, bien réguliers.
Pour faire de beaux anneaux,
c'est dur et c'est long.
Modu avait pris l'habitude de vivre sans entrave
et elle a du mal à supporter cette prison de laiton.
6 kg de métal autour du cou,
mais aussi autour des poignets et des chevilles.
- Au début, quand on porte les anneaux,
on ne se sent pas très bien, on a très mal au cou.
Mais on s'habitue. On n'a plus mal.
Mais c'est difficile.
Par exemple, pour aller aux toilettes,
avec les anneaux aux jambes, ça n'est pas pratique.
Un insupportable carcan qui se referme sur elle
anneau après anneau.
- Attention, tu me fais mal.
Tu tires trop fort, là.
Modu est au bord des larmes.
- Ca me brûle !
- Quand on travaille,
on accumule de la saleté et de la sueur.
Avec le laiton,
ça peut provoquer des problèmes de peau.
Il faut vraiment se laver tous les jours.
Le 16e anneau se referme sur son cou.
Parfois, les femmes girafes
peuvent en porter jusqu'à 28.
- Je ne veux pas que ma fille porte des anneaux,
mais ce sera à elle de décider
si elle veut en porter ou non.
Bientôt, plus personne n'en aura.
Donc je préfère qu'elle ne le fasse pas.
Mahé, au contraire,
est très fière du travail accompli.
A 49 ans, elle est l'une des femmes girafes
les plus âgées de la région.
- Ma grand-mère en avait
et je trouvais qu'elle était belle avec.
La première fois que j'ai mis mes anneaux,
ça a été très douloureux.
Mais je ne sais pas, ça m'a plu
et j'ai voulu en avoir toujours plus.
Jamais, je n'enlèverai mes anneaux.
J'y tiens beaucoup.
Je préfère encore mourir avec.
Aux confins de la Birmanie,
ces femmes girafes sont les dernières
à perpétuer cette tradition.